the men and women graduating today you
come from the rest of us but you are the
best of us you're the pride of your
family and you're the pride of the
American people that was Vice President
Mike Pence addressing graduates of the
US Coast Guard Academy in New London
Connecticut earlier this week members of
the guard are spending this Memorial Day
weekend joining the Navy in Fleet Week
celebrations it's happening here in New
York a city that has a long and storied
history with the Coast Guard
I'm Daler has the story this week more
than a dozen Navy and Coast Guard ships
took part in a 30 year tradition
parading through New York Harbor for
Fleet Week the nautical display lasts
just a few days but the US Coast Guard
patrols the waterways of New York all
year long as Frank Sinatra would say
start spreading the news you are about
to become a Coast Guard city and this
month the city was honored as the
country's 25th and largest Coast Guard
city proclamation of the United States
Coast Guard
the proclamation coming from sector New
York commander captain Michael day is
one of the elements that New York is
welcoming to your presence and your
activities here without a doubt New York
is one the most patriotic one the most
welcoming cities that I've ever been
stationed at it day is in charge of more
than 1,000 active duty and reserve
Guardsmen and women in a city where the
Coast Guard was founded nearly 240 years
ago by Alexander Hamilton right here in
New York City right in federal Holland
in assigned it in August 4th 1790 so
we've got a lot of history here with
with the city of New York what was the
purpose originally it started off as a
Revenue Cutter service as the ships were
coming in and there were people avoiding
paying their taxes so customs types of
type of duty the history may have been
lost on most but not the creator of
Hamilton the musical
this Hamilton the short-tempered Prodi
and creator of the coast god founder of
the New York Post but he just says
creator the coastguard founder of the
New York Post just like randomly if you
were if you're not really listening to
it you would not catch it at all
Michael Liu Weiyi plays Alexander
Hamilton on Broadway that in itself is
sort of like a modicum of what the show
is it speaks volumes to me because it's
just like he did that and he did that
the Coast Guard's presence in New York
has evolved considerably from the
original revenue cutters the service now
oversees everything from maritime
security for the UN General Assembly and
July 4th celebrations in the summer to
ice breaking missions in the Hudson
River in the winter not to mention the
rescues you can't think of the Coast
Guard to not remember say an aircraft
went down in the river and you guys were
right there those are those pictures of
that is there just indelible yeah
Miracle on the Hudson of course
superstorm sandy 911 Coast Guard's
played an integral role in a lot of the
darkest hours for the city captain Dale
ed what's been called America's Dunkirk
the great boat lift of 9/11 became the
largest sea evacuation in history as
explained in the 2011 documentary short
boat lift five hundred thousand people
were rescued from lower Manhattan after
the terrorist attacks on September 11th
2001 all available
this is the United States Coast Guard
York anyone want to help with evacuation
lower Manhattan day organized an amateur
Armada of private boats ferries and
tugboats 15-20 minutes later they're
just boats all across the horizon it
started actually very small-scale but
seeing how efficient it was the Coast
Guard made the call for all available
boats and we're just inundated with help
and getting those people off Captain day
in what you did you change the course of
history for the better
captain days service was recognized by
New York City Mayor Bill DeBlasio days
tour of duty in the city is ending next
month incoming captain Jason Tama will
now lead the sector New York into the
future how would you define what the
Coast Guard's duties are now you know I
think I think a lot you can trace back
to 1790 and as the port has grown and
the population has grown that mission
has become perhaps more dynamic in some
ways but really the roles are
fundamentally the same it's the safety
security and resilience of the harbor
for CBS this morning Saturday Don Dahler
New York